President Trump is welcoming North
Korea's apparent openness to
negotiations about its nuclear program
North Korean leader Kim jong-un
reportedly told South Korean officials
this week that he's willing to discuss
giving up his country's nuclear weapons
and suspending its nuclear program
during any talks president Trump called
the statements very positive it's not
yet clear whether the you asked would
meet the North Koreans Republican
senator Cory Gardner of Colorado is on
the Foreign Relations Committee he
chairs the Subcommittee on East Asia the
Pacific and international cybersecurity
policies with us from Capitol Hill for
an interview you'll only see on CBS this
morning senator good morning what do you
make of North Korea's position are they
reacting to sanctions are they pausing
to reload or is this a part of a long
pattern of kind of cat-and-mouse there
is no doubt that the sanctions that have
been put in place against the Kim regime
are starting to work I've talked to
officials at the CIA the State
Department they're starting to feel the
pressure from significant sanctions not
only from the United States but from our
allies and partners around the globe but
we've also been here before and so we
have to take this certainly it's
positive but we have to take this sign
and this gesture to talk not only with a
grain of salt but with perhaps an entire
salt block so senator what is the next
move as you'd advise for the
administration in terms of not being
fooled again from what the North Koreans
have done before in the past the United
States has lived up to our end of the
bargain where we've entered into
promises or agreements with North Korea
only to see the North Koreans break
their end of the bargain and so what
this administration needs to continue to
do is apply maximum pressure as it has
continuing to engage China and other
countries around the world to enforce
stricter standards in stricter sanctions
to make sure the United Nations
continues to put pressure on them and
then go after the the heinous that
heinous slave labor practices of the
North Korean regime to cut off even more
dollars that go back to prop up kim
jeong-hoon so there's plenty of action
that can be taken and this
administration needs to take every
single one of them let me ask you the
South Korean leader that met with Kim
jong-un said that he received a pledge
from Kim jong-un that
would halt testing if during these
negotiations do you believe them when
they say that well if they halt testing
that doesn't mean that they halt their
progress I think they've reached the
stage and their nuclear program we're
sure they can say look we're not gonna
we're not gonna test but in the meantime
they continue to develop supply lines
develop new technologies testing through
computer models it doesn't mean that
they give up or completely halt their
nuclear program that's a big difference
but I think it's important to go back to
what they have said they would do in the
past they've actually said they would do
more in terms of agreeing with us to
give up their nuclear program this is
one of their lesser promises they've
made and so we must continue maximum
pressure and not give up on our desire
our demand of complete verifiable
irreversible denuclearization
so how optimistic are you senator you
tweeted yesterday that we need to make
sure I'm paraphrasing that we avoid the
mistakes we made in the past you feeling
optimistic and what mistakes where are
you referring to
well I again the mistakes that we have
made in terms of believing that kid the
the Kim family his father his
grandfather was serious about the
actions that he was going to take
there's no doubt that we have to have a
resolution and again I agree this is a
positive development but will that
positive development that lead to
concrete results of denuclearization and
that's what we have to have so I am
skeptical this is a good thing but we
have to make sure that we're not fooled
as the old saying goes and not fooled
twice shame on us what do you make of
the resignation of Gary cone yesterday
from the White House what do you make of
that and the president has tweeted
there's no chaos here yeah I think the
op tempo of the White House as you know
is incredibly different than many other
White House administrations I think this
is probably something that Gary has
thought about long and hard over the
past several months as he obviously has
different things that he could be doing
in the private sector I look forward to
sitting down and talking with him about
how we can continue to work with the
administration on trade agreements that
are in his remaining time trade
agreements that are fair to the American
people but also don't punish the
American people through a punitive trade
actions but the precipitating event in
this case was the president's steel
tariffs you are in charge of getting
Republicans elected most Republicans
don't agree with those tariffs how do
they and Paul Ryan has said
tariffs are gonna walk back some of the
gains from the tax cut how do you sell
Republicans to the public when on the
one hand taxes are helping them but in
this case according to Paul Ryan it's
hurting them well there's no doubt that
the president campaigned on this issue
so there's not a surprise to anyone who
was following the campaign that the
president made this decision and I think
he's right to say we need trade
agreements they're fair where I disagree
with of course is on the decision to
impose a tariff on steel aluminum or to
withdraw from NAFTA that could actually
hurt the American people I represent a
state that has a lot of great beer
industries a lot of farmers who are very
worried about the impact steel aluminum
tariffs could have on them trade deals
like NAFTA very important to them so
let's make sure they're fair let's make
sure they're good for the American
people but if we take the wrong economic
policies and I think imposing a tariff
is then it could lead to higher costs on
the American consumer it could cost jobs
instead of saving jobs and that's not
the right step so I look forward to
continuing to work with the White House
to make sure that we do the right thing
and not something that could hurt all
right senator Gardner thanks so much for
being us